donantes incluyendo el banco mundial la
unión europea ue se suspendieron su
financiación regular a afganistán porque
no pueden enviar fondos por medio de las
autoridades talibanas la organización
mundial de la salud alerta que como
resultado más de 2300 instalaciones
médicas afganas cerrarían en cuestión de
días
según algunas estimaciones cerca del 90%
probablemente dejarán de funcionar a lo
largo de esta semana algo que podría
conllevar un aumento de las enfermedades
y las defunciones y un retroceso de los
enormes progresos de los últimos 20 años
si los cierres perdura
lado ms asegura que espera enviar
material médico por vía aérea
próximamente el objetivo es lograr que
500 centros médicos permanezcan abiertos
esperamos que llegue uno de los vuelos
del programa mundial de alimentos que
esta semana amasar
y el gobierno de qatar también nos
ofreció ayuda y esperamos que mande
entre dos o tres cargos con suministros
probablemente a kabul estas semanas
y el personal de la salud afgana
protesto la semana pasada en kabul
pidiendo a la comunidad internacional
que mantenga su ayuda financiera
asegurando que millones de afganos
corren el riesgo de quedarse sin
atención médica y que 26.000
trabajadores médicos incluyendo 7500
mujeres podrían perder sus empleos